chers amis qu'elle est finalement
l'enjeu de cette élection régionale
l'enjeu c'est face à l'amateurisme
socialistes parisiens de construire une
crédibilité et un professionnalisme des
républicains dans les régions c'est ça
l'enjeu on voit bien que la gauche est
aux abois
nous avons à construire cette
crédibilité et nous avons à faire des
régions que nous allons reconquérir des
laboratoires pour l'échéance de 2017
qu'ont fait les socialistes depuis 2004
depuis que cette première vague rose
avait envahi nos régions eh bien ils ont
fait du socialisme ils ont et roger l'a
très bien décrit tout à l'heure ils ont
augmenté les dépenses de fonctionnement
ils ont fait linverse philippe richert
en alsace et ils ont fait du
clientélisme
je peux vous raconter une anecdote
j'étais vice président de région avec
jean claude étienne ans de 1998
nous regardions les dossiers de manière
le cube et nick c'est à dire que nous
avons autant aider la ville de sedan
laura lorsqu'elle a construit son stade
alors qu elle était gérée par un maire
socialiste que la ville de troyes qui
était à l'époque et encore géré par
notre ami françois baroin est bien le
successeur
le successeur de jean claude etienne à
la région jean paul bachy actuel régime
présidente champagne ardenne qu'est ce
qu'il a fait il a fait de la politique
c'est à dire que la ville de chaumont
lorsqu'elle a investi de manière
structurante pour rénover son centre
ville n'a pas eu un centime de la région
ça c'est la région ça c'est la vision
socialiste des régions c'est le
clientélisme c'est la politique
politicienne des socialistes nous nous
devront être exemplaires être exemplaire
c'est ne pas commencer par aller
construire un siège pour une nouvelle
région
ce serait agrandi être exemplaire c'est
éviter de mobiliser tous les dépenses de
fonctionnement dans des dépenses
inutiles être exemplaire c'est
s'attacher aux vrais problèmes de nos
concitoyens de nos compatriotes
la laboratoire c'est être capable d'être
innovant en 2017 nous aurons à inventer
des solutions en matière de gestion
publique et bien les régions peuvent
être des laboratoires par exemple pour
externaliser certaines dépenses de
fonctionnement par exemple pour mettre
en place une administration digital une
administration dématérialisé qui fasse
faire des économies en matière de
fonctionnement c'est essentiel que nous
soyons novateur que nous soyons innovant
par rapport à de nouvelles solutions
et puis enfin nous devrons répondre à la
question majeure des français et les
compétences des régions peuvent nous
permettre d'y répandre en matière
économique et en matière d'apprentissage
c'est évidemment l'emploi
là encore tournons le dos à des gestions
de développement économiques du passé
je me souviens avoir participé à des
commissions permanentes ou dotés des
petites entreprises de quelques milliers
d'euros ont saupoudré les entrepreneurs
et nous disent mais attendez nous on
veut pas de subventions nous ce qu'on
veut c'est que la région soit à nos
côtés sur des grands choix stratégiques
qu'elles soient capables de nous aider
en matière d'innovation en matière de
recherche et développement d'accompagner
nos projets que nous chassions en meute
à l'international c'est ça qu'attendent
les entreprises elles attendent pas un
saupoudrage sur l'ensemble du territoire
donc nous avons là aussi à montrer notre
crédibilité a montré qu'elle est notre
vision en matière économique
nous ne sommes pas dans l'assistanat
nous ne sommes pas dans le dirigisme
économique
ce que nous voulons c'est créer les
conditions de développement des pme de
l'amélioration de l'augmentation du
nombre d'apprentis
ayez en tête qu'en france il y a cinq
fois moins cinq fois moins d'apprentis
dans les entreprises de 250
500 personnes qu'en allemagne ça c'est
un beau challenge pour nos futurs
présidents de région donc en clair le
défi des républicains le défi des
républicains tout simplement mes chers
amis c'est la revanche des territoires
faisons de nos régions un laboratoire de
reconquête pour 2017